Hi.
In this session, we're going to
cover a nice review problem
that will look at how
to infer one random
variable based on another.
And in this problem, we're given
two random variables--
X and Y--
and we're also given their joint
pdf, which we're told is
a constant 2/3 within the
region bounded by
these orange lines.
And outside of the region,
the joint pdf is 0.
So the first thing we're going
to look at, or the first thing
that we're asked to do, is find
the LMS estimator of Y
based on X. Now, remember that
LMS estimator is really just a
conditional expectation.
So the LMS estimator of Y based
on X is the conditional
expectation of Y, given X.
Now, when we have a plot of
the joint pdf and we're
dealing with these two random
variables, and especially when
the joint pdf is constant like
this, it's often easy to
calculate this conditional
expectation visually.
So what we really need to do
is just say, given any
particular value of X, what
is the conditional
expectation of Y?
So what we can do is we can just
pick some values of X and
see visually what that initial
expectation is.
So for example, if X is 1/2,
given that X is 1/2, and since
this whole joint pdf is uniform,
then the conditional
slice of Y will be from
here to here.
And that slice, the conditional
distribution of Y,
given that X is 1/2, will
also be uniform.
So it'll be uniform
from here to here.
And if it's uniform, we know
that the conditional
expectation will just be
the midpoint here.
And so that would be what the
conditional expectation of Y
would be, given that X is 1/2.
And we could do the same
thing for X equals 1.
And we'll see that again,
because everything is uniform,
this slice is also going
to be uniform.
And so the conditional
expectation will again be the
midpoint, which is there.
And then if we just look at it
within this region, it's
always going to be
the midpoint.
And so we get that the initial
expectation of Y, given X,
will just look like that line,
which you can think of it as
just bisecting this angle formed
by these two parts of
the region.
But things are a little bit
different, though, when we
move to the region where
X is between 1 and 2.
Between 1 and 2, say
at 1 and 1/2, this
line doesn't continue.
Because now, the slice of Y goes
from here to here, and
again, it's still uniform.
So the midpoint would
be there.
And similarly for X equals
2, it would be here.
And so for X between 1 and 2,
the conditional expectation
actually looks like this.
So you see that there's actually
two linear parts of
it, but there's a kink
at X equals 1.
And so by looking at this
visually and taking advantage
of the fact that everything is
uniform, we can pretty easily
figure out what this conditional
expectation is.
So now, let's actually just
write it out algebraically.
So for X between 0 and 1, we
said that it's this line,
which if we look at it, that's
just 1/2 of X. Now, this is
for X between 0 and 1.
And if X is between 1 and 2,
it's going to be this line,
which is a slope of 1.
And if we extend this
down, it hits the
y-axis at negative 1/2.
So it's X minus 1/2, if
X is between 1 and 2.
And otherwise, it's undefined.
So we'll focus on these
two cases here.
Now, the second part of the
question, now that we know
what the LMS estimator is, we're
asked to find what is
the traditional mean squared
error of this estimator?
So we want to know
how good is it.
And one way of capturing
that is to look at the
mean squared error.
And so recall that the
conditional mean squared error
is given by this expression.
So what we're saying is this is
what we estimate Y to be.
This is what y really is, so
this difference is how wrong,
or the error in our estimate.
We square it, because otherwise,
positive and
negative errors might cancel
each other out,
so we square it.
And then this just looking
at each individual
value of x for now.
So this is why it's
the conditional
mean squared error.
So how do we calculate this?
Well, remember that this g of
X, we said the LMS estimator
is just a conditional
expectation.
So it's just expectation
of Y, given X.
Well, then if you look at this,
what this reminds you
of, it reminds you of the
definition of what a
conditional variance is.
A variance is just, you take the
random variable, subtract
its mean, square it, and take
the expectation of that.
This is no different, except
that everything is now the
conditional world of X.
So this is actually the
conditional variance of Y,
given X is little x.
What is the conditional
variance of Y, given
that X is little x?
Now, we can again go back
to this plot to
try to help us out.
We can split this up
into regions again.
So just take some little x as
an example and see what the
variance is.
So if little x is 1/2, then we
know that the conditional
distribution of Y would
be uniform, we said,
from 0 up to here.
Well, that point is this
from 0 to 1/2.
And remember, the variance of a
uniform distribution is just
the width of the uniform
distribution
squared, divided by 12.
And so in this case, the width
would be 1/2 squared over 12.
And in general, for the region
of X between 0 and 1, the
width of the conditional
distribution of Y will always
be X, because the width will
go from 0 to wherever X is.
So because of that, the
conditional variance will just
be X squared, the width squared,
over 12, when X is
between 0 and 1.
Now, let's think about the
other case, where X is
between 1 and 2.
Well, if X is between 1 and
2, we're over here.
And now, if we take the
conditional distribution of Y,
it's again uniform.
But the width now, instead of
varying with Y, it's always
going to be the same width.
Each of these slices have the
same width, and the width goes
from here-- this is X minus
1, and that's X.
So if the width is always going
to be a constant of 1.
And so this variance is
going to be 1/12.
And from that, we get our answer
for the conditional
mean squared error.
Now, part c asks us to find the
mean squared error, which
is given by this expression.
And we'll see that it looks very
similar to this, which
was the conditional mean
squared error.
And now, given what we
know from part b,
this is easy to calculate.
We can just apply total
expectation, because this is
just equal to the integral
of the conditional
mean squared error.
And then we need to also
multiply this by the pf of x,
and then integrate over X. And
that integral will should be
from X equals 0 to 2, because
that's the only range that
applies for x, given
this joint pdf.
Now, in order to do this first,
though, we need to
figure out what the
pdf of X is.
In order to do that, we can go
back to our original joint pdf
of X and Y and marginalize it.
So marginalizing, you could
think of it as taking this
joint pdf and collapsing it onto
the x-axis so that you
take everything and
integrate out Y.
Now to do that, let's
do that up here.
We can split it up into
two sections.
So the section of X between 0
and 1, we integrate the joint
pdf from Y equals 0 to Y
equals X, which is this
portion of this line.
So we integrate Y. The joint pdf
is 2/3, and we integrate Y
out from Y equals 0 to X. And
then for the portion of X from
1 to 2, we again integrate
Y out.
Now we integrate Y from
X minus 1 up to X.
So this is X between 0 and 1,
and this is X between 1 and 2.
So we just do some little bit
of calculus, and we get that
this is going to be 2/3 X when
X is between 0 and 1.
And it's going to be 2/3 when
X is between 1 and 2.
So now that we have what the
marginal pdf of X is, we can
plug that into this, and plug in
what we had for b, and then
calculate what this
actually is.
So remember, we need to take
care of these two cases, these
two regions--
X between 0 and 1, and
X between 1 and 2.
So the conditional mean squared
error for X between 0
and 1 is X squared over 2.
So between 0 and 1, this first
part is X squared over 12.
The pdf of X in that same
region is 2/3 x.
And we integrate that in the
region from x equals 0 to 1.
And then, we also have the
second region which
is X from 1 to 2.
In that region, the traditional
mean squared error
from part b is 1/12.
The marginal pdf of X is 2/3,
and we do this integral.
And if you just carry out some
calculus here, you'll get that
the final answer is
equal to 5/72.
Now, the last part of this
question asks us, is this mean
squared error the same thing--
does it equal the expectation
of the conditional variance?
And it turns out that
yes, it does.
And to see that, we can just
take this, and use the law of
iterated expectations, because
iterated expectations tells us
this is in fact equal to the
expectation of Y minus g of X
squared, given X. That's just
applying law of iterated
expectations.
And then, if we look at this,
this part that's inside is
exactly equal to the conditional
variance of Y,
given X. And so these two
are, in fact, the same.
In part c, we calculated what
the marginal pdf of X is, and
it'll actually be used later
on in this problem.
So for future reference, let's
just write it down here in
this corner.
Now, so far in this
problem, we've
looked at the LMS estimator.
And of course, there are
other estimators that
you can use as well.
And now in part d, let's look
at the linear LMS estimator.
Now remember, the linear LMS
estimator is special, because
it forces the estimator to have
a linear relationship.
So the estimator is going to
be a linear function of X.
Now, compare that
to what the LMS
estimator was in this case.
It was two linear pieces,
but there was a kink.
And so the entire estimator
wasn't actually linear in X.
Now, the LLMS estimator, or the
linear LMS estimator, will
give us the linear estimator.
It's going to be a linear
function of X.
And we know that we have
a formula for this.
Is the expectation of Y plus the
covariance of X and Y over
the variance of X times X minus
expectation of X. All
right, so in order to calculate
what this is, we
just need to calculate
what four things are.
Now, let's start with this last
one, the expected value
of X. To calculate the expected
value of X, we just
use a formula.
And from before, we know
what the pdf of X is.
And so we know that this
is just going to be X
times fx of x dx.
And in particular, this will
give us that from 0 to 1, it's
going to be X times the
pdf of X is 2/3 X,
so it's 2/3 X squared.
And from 1 to 2, it's going to
be X times the pdf of X, which
is just 2/3, so it's 2/3 X dx.
And when you calculate
this out, you'll get
that is equal to 11/9.
Now, let's calculate the
variance of X next.
In order to calculate that,
let's use the formula that
variance is equal to the
expectation of X squared minus
the expectation of X
quantity squared.
We had the expectation of X,
so let's calculate what the
expectation of X squared is.
Now, it's the same idea.
Instead, we have X squared
times f of X dx.
And we'll get the same
sort of formula.
We'll split it up again into
two different parts from X
equals 0 to X equals 1.
It's going to be X squared
times pdf, so
it's 2/3 X cubed dx.
And then from X equals 1 to
2, it's going to be X
squared times 2/3.
So it's 2/3 X squared dx.
And when we calculate this
out, we'll get that
it's equal to 31/18.
From that, we know that the
variance is going to be equal
to expectation of X squared
minus expectation of X
quantity squared.
Now, expectation of X
squared is 31/18.
Expectation of X is 11/9.
And when we calculate this,
we get that the
variance is equal to 37/162.
So now we have this,
and we have that.
Let's calculate what expectation
of Y is.
Expectation of Y, let's
calculate it using the law of
iterated expectations.
The law of iterated expectations
tells us that
this is equal to the expectation
of Y conditioned
on X.
Now, we already know what
expectation of Y
conditioned on X is.
That was the LMS estimator that
we calculated earlier.
It's this.
So now we just need to
calculate this out,
and we can do that.
So we know that in the range
from X between 0 and 1, it's
equal to 1/2 X. So in the range
from 0 to 1, it's equal
to 1/2 X. But then, we have to
use total expectation, so we
have to multiply by the pdf
of X in that region
which is 2/3 X dx.
And then in the range from
X equals 1 to 2, this
conditional expectation
is X minus 1/2.
And the pdf of X in that
region is 2/3.
Now, when we calculate out this
value, we'll get that
it's equal to 7/9.
And now, the last piece is the
covariance of X and Y.
Remember, the covariance, we
can calculate that as the
expectation of X times Y minus
the expectation of X times the
expectation of Y. We already
know the expectation of X and
the expectation of Y, so we
just need to calculate the
expectation of X times Y,
the product of the two.
And for that, we'll use the
definition, and we'll use the
joint pdf that we have.
So this is going to be a double
integral of X times Y
times the joint pdf.
And the tricky part here is just
figuring out what these
limits are.
So we'll integrate
in this order--
X and Y.
Now, let's split this up.
So let's focus on
splitting X up.
So for X between 0 and 1, we
just need to figure out what's
the rate right range of Y to
integrate over such that this
is actually non-zero.
Because remember, the
joint pdf is easy.
It's just a constant 2/3.
But it's only a constant
2/3 within this region.
So the difficult part is just
figuring out what the limits
are in order to specify
that region.
So for X between 0 and 1, Y
has to be between 0 and X,
because this line is Y equals
X. So we need to integrate
from 0 to X--
X times Y times the joint
pdf, which is 2/3.
And now, let's do the other
part, which is X from 1 to 2.
Well, if X is from 1 to 2, in
order to fall into this
region, Y has to be between X
minus 1 and X. So we integrate
Y from X minus 1 to X. Against,
it's X times Y times
the joint pdf, which is 2/3.
And now, once we have this set
up, the rest of it we can just
do some calculus.
And what we find is
that the final
answer is equal to 41/36.
Now, what that tells us is that
the covariance of X and
Y, which is just expectation
of X times Y, the product,
minus expectation of X times
expectation of Y.
We know expectation
of X times Y now.
It's 41/36.
Expectation of X is 11/9.
Expectation of Y is 7/9.
So when we substitute all of
that in, we get that this
covariance is 61/324.
All right, so now we have
everything we need.
Expectation of Y is here.
Covariance is here.
Variance of X is here.
And expectation of X is here.
So let's substitute that in, and
we can figure out what the
actual LLMS estimator is.
So expectation of Y
we know is 7/9.
Expectation of X is 11/9.
And when you divide the
covariance, which is 61/324,
by the variance, which is
37/162, we'll get 61/74.
And so that is the LLMS
estimator that we calculated.
And notice that it is,
in fact, linear in X.
So let's plot that and see
what it looks like.
So it's going to be a
line, and it's going
to look like this.
So at X equals 2, it's actually
a little bit below 1
and 1/2, which is what the
LMS estimator would be.
At X equals 1, it's actually a
little bit above 1/2, which is
what the LMS estimator
would be.
And then it crosses 0 around
roughly 1/4, and it drops
actually below 0.
So if we connect the dots,
it's going to look
something like this.
So notice that it's actually not
too far away from the LMS
estimator here.
But it doesn't have the kink
because it is a line.
And note also that it actually
drops below.
So when X is very small, you
actually estimate negative
values of Y, which is actually
impossible, given the joint
pdf distribution that
we're given.
And that is sometimes a feature
or artifact of the
linear LMS estimator, that
you'll get values that don't
necessarily seem
to make sense.
So now that we've calculated
the linear LMS estimator in
part d, which is this, and the
LMS estimator in part a, which
is this, we've also compared
them visually.
The linear LMS estimator
is the one in pink,
the straight line.
And the LMS estimator is the
one in black with the kink.
It's an interesting question
to now ask, which
one of these is better?
And in order to judge that, we
need to come up with some sort
of criterion to compare
the two with.
And the one that we're going
to look at in part e is the
mean squared error.
Which one gives the lower
And so specifically, we're going
to ask ourselves which
of these two estimators
gives us the smaller
mean squared error?
Is it the linear LMS estimator
given by l of X?
Or is it the LMS estimator,
given by g of X?
Now, we know that the LMS
estimator is the one that
actually minimizes this.
The LMS estimator is designed
to minimize the
mean squared error.
And so we know that given any
estimator of X, this one will
have the smallest mean
squared error.
And so the linear LMS estimator,
its mean squared
error has to be at least as
large as the LMS estimators.
And the last part of the
question now asks us to look
at a third type of estimator,
which is the MEP estimator.
Now, we want to ask, why is it
that we haven't been using the
MEP estimator in this problem?
Well, remember what the
MEP estimator does.
In this case, what we would
do is it would take the
conditional distribution ratio
of Y given any value of X. And
then it would pick the value
of Y that gives the highest
value in the conditional
distribution.
And that would be the
MEP estimate of Y.
But the problem in this case is
that if you take any slice
here, so a condition on any
value of X, any of these
slices, if you just take this
out and look at it, it's going
to be uniform.
This is what the conditional
distribution of Y given X is.
It's going to be uniform between
0 and X. Now, what the
MEP rule tells us is we're going
to pick the value of Y
that gives us the highest point
in this conditional
distribution.
You can think of it as a
posterior distribution.
Now, what's the problem here?
Well, every single point gives
us exactly the same value for
this conditional distribution.
And so there's no
unique MEP rule.
Every single value of Y has
just the same conditional
distribution.
So there's no sensible way of
choosing a value based on the
MEP rule in this case.
But compare that with the LMS
estimator, which is just get
conditional expectation.
In that case, we can always
find a conditional
expectation.
In this case, the conditional
expectation is the midpoint,
which is X/2, just as
had found in part a.
OK, so in this problem, we
reviewed a bunch of different
ideas in terms of inference, and
we took a joint pdf of X
and Y, and we used that to
calculate the LMS estimator,
the linear LMS estimator.
We compared the two, and then we
also looked at why in this
case, the MEP estimator doesn't
really make sense.
All right, so I hope that
was helpful, and we'll
see you next time.